alicia how are we doing i just want to
get you know kind of your
your advice on how does one approach
marriage after growing up with divorced
parents
that's an interesting question so
where's that question stemming from are
you about to get married
i'm in a serious relationship just about
two and a half years and we're
meeting my current boyfriend uh in very
serious talks you know within next year
kind of you know preparing for for that
next step
but so before that next step i just have
i have a little hesitation
not from not believing in marriage but
definitely waves in the back of my mind
having
um the force parenting going through
that it's just
it's one of those things i feel like
they could do everything right to
prepare
but you can't predict the future still
right
so let's answer this big question number
one by the way you may have heard me
laugh
you said we're in very serious talks and
that's like contract negotiation
language that i read like on espn.com so
the way you said that was awesome like
like he put an offer on the table
and you're thinking i don't know about
that i'll take this offer so that just
made me laugh so
this is a serious conversation how were
you
hurt by your parents divorce
um mainly i was 15
so you know prime age freshman high
school and an only child
oh man it was very close to becoming
still captioning not
never spoke available of each other in
front of me they put me first 100
they co-parented i mean they really did
an excellent job after that
um but some of you just can't take away
some of that you know pain and hurt that
it came with
and still today um having just to deal
with it small
things like you know two houses for
thanksgiving or christmas
and you know just it still exists today
even though we're
you know 10 years in the future and just
a really great place now
so why in the world would you even want
to get married
who's this guy you're married what's his
name um
his name is matthew why in the world
would you even be considering matthew
you've seen it go south you see what
happens and you saw it happen with
people who handle it well
really well yeah why in the world would
you marry matthew
uh well i do i still believe in
marriage and you know really having a
partner you know in life and
why why why do you believe in that why
do you believe in that i think
i didn't know because i saw it for like
a lot of years my parents for the most
part had a very healthy marriage they
were a team
you know they were young when they had
me they just fought hard and they worked
really hard and
um just putting me first and it was so i
had a
really good childhood a very loving home
um and things still didn't work out so
there was a
there was a part of me but now meeting
even before me matthew i still have you
know that hope that you get married
um but then after meeting matthew and
seeing um
he's just a great person and just the
best partner
that i mean he's just like the best
teammate
um and just very very good
so i want to change some of your
language okay
you i loved you listening to you talk
about your parents
right they loved each other they fought
for it they went for it and then you
tossed in something that was
a throwaway line but it is really heavy
and it's really existential
and i want you to never forget what i'm
about to tell you okay
okay the phrase it just didn't work
out is not real when it comes to
relationships
oh 100 somebody whether it was one
or both made a decision to no longer
continue rebuilding to continue
investing and they pulled their chips
off the table and said i'm out
right 100 and so when you get
married we live in a culture
right you know the stats as well as i do
every friend you have probably has
parents who are divorced every friend
i've got not everyone a number of them
have parents who are divorced
and even some of those who are still
married are just roommates right
we see those you and i both experienced
that and so
the reason i was asking you why even do
this why go down this road
and you answer a question
right because having a partner is worth
it
and finding somebody and saying i'm all
in
and i'm gonna continue to be all in even
as the game changes
as the tables change as the number of
chips we both have to play changes
as we continue down this wild adventure
it's all going to continue to shift and
change and this phrase it just didn't
work out
is a decision it's not a
a just for some it does and for some it
doesn't right
and so if you decide to get married to
this guy and you're in very serious
negotiations right now right
right you're very serious talks
i want you to both agree right now that
divorce is
never on the table it is not an option
it can't be an option it won't be an
option
and we're never gonna even have it here
to discuss
and talk through and so once an option
is off the table
then it's it's not an outcome then you
have to
do the other side of that equation which
is let's build
a marriage where we always plan things
together
where we always commit to being
radically honest with one another but
not idiotic honest and there's a
difference
where we budget together and we dream
together and we talk about when those
dreams
change and we express fears and we are
vulnerable with one another and we talk
about past hurts with one another
all these things that somehow stop over
the course of a relationship
and commit to that front end and commit
to
never having divorce as an option
and then your relationship is going to
be as build
i mean as strong as you invest in the
architecture and the continued
re-engineering of this thing
and so i'm going to give you the magic
word here
if you don't want to get divorced choose
not to
marry somebody that chooses not to
and can i give you one more
uncomfortable moment
yes all relationship 100
of it is a risk and it's a risk
on the front end and it's a risk all the
way through it
and if you knew the outcome if you knew
how it ends it wouldn't be a
relationship
right it would be a it would be a
business arrangement
and so no going in that there is no
there is no guarantee on the back end
that's what makes it so exciting and so
scary and so
beautiful right it's a choice
and so as you hear me say that it sounds
trite and silly right
thank you no talk to me about it
well no it yeah it doesn't sound silly
just i i very much
know a person who um likes control and
would you know like to do like
everything to work out
but because i made every right decision
i possibly could so
um i think since now but up until
now i haven't really looked beyond you
know five years in the future whether it
was high school
and college and you know early in my
career so now
the thought you know looking okay let's
stream
you know 10 20 30 years in the future
it's like whoa whoa that feels like out
of my reach that i have control over
um you know it is just scary and and
that's basically it
and uh and that is that hey that's the
rest of your life
that's what's so cool about this that
never goes away
the moment it stops being scary is the
moment that people start looking over
the shoulder
right the moment that people get
comfortable and they lean back and
they're like that's all right
is the moment they stop investing in new
architecture
they stop trying to build a stronger
foundation
they stop trying to do the repair work
on on this relationship
and then the whole thing they find it in
ash
right so it is risky it is exhausting it
is forever
and whatever you think you're planning
for 20 years from now i promise
i promise it will be different i work on
the radio
now i have instagram for god's sake
i had like one promise on earth is that
i would never have instagram
that was stupid right so whatever my
plan was
i wish i could go back and tell you what
my plans were when me and my wife were
dating
it probably involved i don't even want
to get into it it's not what my life is
now and my life is
a thousand times better than i could
have pictured it and for whatever it's
worth
there have been multiple two or three or
four times
over the 20-plus years i've been dating
and have been married to my wife
when we reached an apex and said this
could be
this could be it and we chose not to
we chose not to quote unquote
just say ah let's call it it didn't work
out
we didn't take our chips off the table
we may have got up and walked away from
the table for a minute and walked around
and then sat back down and said these
are the cards i've got what cards do you
have let's lay it all out on the table
and let's rebuild again and let's
rebuild again and let's keep rebuilding
again
i love alicia i love that you're asking
these questions i love that you are a
person who loves control
and i want you to know
you are you are putting that on the
table when you go all
in on somebody else and if you're
listening to this and you don't under
you don't hear anything else i'm high on
marriage i still think it's got
it's it's one of the most important
cultural touchstones of our time
and i don't believe and things just run
their course i don't believe in things
just
didn't work out i believe that people
change
and i believe people grow and i believe
people change and grow together
and i also believe people at some point
just cash in and say i'm out
i'm done i can't be here with you
because you won't do x
i can't be there with y because she
won't do x y and z
and it's a risk it's a risk it's all in
it's a risk
but alicia i said go for it